Mà cái vị đưa sạy thì đây là lần đầu tiên mà tụi em được tránh như thế bây giờ nặng nhanh chân
Nếu tại vô thì tăng sức mề trực chân, sẽ lại là khi mà tráo tại bà thì cái cựch cho nông sẽ đều nâng
Nặng khó khăn tụi nặng ngủ là như tên tình ngủ nhưng mà mình có mọi người lật thôi
Hãy ngủ mình cái như gần, cắn ngủ mình như thế này, nhưng mà phải gìm hơn gọi cho nâng mọi lại
Bước đi bộng chắc, cái lúc mà cho tập tạy thì chân nó, đi nó không được chắc chân lắm
Còn không đứa được gần, có lúc cho nâng, cái cựch cho nó kìm được gì biac
Bước thì tập kì chân trên đá, bước thì tập tìm được, bước thì tập tìm được
Còn người thương và măng tà, sẽ tăng được thì cơ chân, mà đối bên của gần chân
Cơ chân măng tà của xáng, hãy tiếp, bối chió thì một chơi thì chó tởi thư điểm này thì cứ bàn
Tống cội đã sạp mình của trong buối lần đầu tiên đều để phía dạ tứng hội không?